citizens of the reject Nation it is John it
is Tara Erickson said my full name that's
right people only say my full name welcome to
the club and if you're mad about that you're
going to be even matter when you discover
that you're gonna like this when we're mad
because today we're checking out 2003's Hulk
Ah that's right not Mark Ruffalo not Edward
Norton not Lou Ferrigno But Eric the binna
checking out Ong Lee's film haven't seen a
lick of this but I remember it it being a
hotly debated film when it first came out
so hey don't forget to smash that like Hulk out on
the subscription button and when you do right now
oh and that way we won't be mad at all
because you'll be here with us and we'll
all be together but anyway guys check out
Tara Erickson on the social medias check
out La eats and drinks as well get some food
advice if you're stopping by La and speaking
of beloved comic book characters if you
happen to be in San Diego this coming
weekend sdcc Greg Coy and I will be there for
a panel on Saturday one o'clock in the library
come join us we'll be very mad if you don't
come join us and finally people if you want
to get the full experience of Hulk alongside us
see everything that doesn't make these reaction
highlights come on over to patreon.com the real
rejects we got a ton of other movies and shows
over there it's a lot of fun and without
further Ado Tara I'm ready you're ready
[Music]
oh [Music]
old school looks vaguely like the Goosebumps slime
almost I do I do miss these intros whoa that was
really relaxing until it wasn't yeah I missed
these intros where it's like ooh microscopic
science thematic you know yeah representation
of what's to come bioluminescence rapid
response [Music] you trying to recreate humans or
live forever I can make super immune systems by
strengthening the human cellular response manner
I know where you're going but manipulating the
immune system is dangerous and stupid dangerous
and stupid is what we're all about no human
subjects he said no humans subjects man this
guy is trying to be a hero I'm gonna have a
baby or no what's her name Jesus I don't know her
name [Applause] you got some little regenerative
abilities passed on to you up it's been
passed on okay interesting transitions [Music]
oh okay a purple and green jeans Rose your hurts
oh Bruce strange I didn't make a peep he's
like that he's just so bottled up holding
it all in the samples we found in your lab
they were human blood you've ignored protocol
you had no right snooping around in my lab it's
government business and you're off the project oh
man don't fly off into a rage dude blow
it all up failsafe has been initiated
I love this oh David what's going
on David Banner who's there Bruce
stay here what [Music] what's going
on the killer in there oh is it him
oh oh hello sir baby face Banner yeah man good
morning Stanley and Lou Ferrigno perfect can I
just ask are you wearing the helmet while she
dumped you see it protects my very important
Brain Harper always wears hey oh girl hey
review board we have to make a presentation
on Tuesday that's working together after being
so close if I could be warm whatever you know
your boyfriend again I don't know why but like
she hasn't aged like how she looks right now is
how she looks in the new Top Gun movie she
like looks the same they're actually gonna
figure out you know the serums they used to keep
her that way in this movie give me some of that
serum girl and a man's fully dispersed let's hit
Freddie with the camera radiation gamma radiation
imbalanced nanomed activity oh yeah that doesn't
look good he's bubbling over oh my
God is he gonna explode oh my God
that looked very painful how'd
you like to come work for Atheon
get paid 10 times as much as you are now and on
a piece of patents those patent rights two words
that's not a no I would have Benny Benny's dead
I'm the new guy uh sound good sounds ominous
I know that voice oh remember
good old Kodak print out pictures
wow that is a show whoa okay Harry Potter
she's gonna leave the kid there she's fine she's
a military brat she can take care of herself
whoa damn
that was the lab explosion looked like [Music]
whoa what I just want to say that little
girl was very believable yeah I was like
how they get her to cry like that that's what
I think in every Steven Spielberg film and now
sense something about you
okay this is like is he this is like a
bad dream okay good old nightmare is it that
dog you followed him home oh oh my it is
plus a creepy janitor
oh my God like I know that voice anywhere oh my
God I wonder if he was like drinking when he was
filming this you and I have never had the chance
to get to know each other properly well it's
because I don't want to get to know you properly
or improper probably or biblically or otherwise
here forth and into eternity I just wanted to
say don't worry about him I'll handle it oh
With Your Love
you walked right past the hazmat suits
oh God drama whoa whoa whoa whoa this
is nope get out of there oh geez what
in the actual I can't stop it oh no oh
no get out get out yeah get out get out
of there what are you doing oh [__]
oh boy never better oh okay still get nightmares
though bro yeah still dreaming about Critters
on the other side you're wondering why you're
still alive you're thinking there's something
inside inexplicable like a snowflake I can help
you understand forgive me I'm sure I have nothing
to forgive you for you don't know that yet dig a
Little Deeper you may not want to believe it but I
can see it in your eyes so much like your mother
s Miss Ross again there's something you need to
know about our Bruce something Troublesome
let me protect you from her this is intense
huh yes all right getting to work Jerry riggin
foreign [Music] [Applause]
doodle gamma radiation experimentation in my spare
time it's cringe where you work with you know who
he really is oh I think I was hoping that maybe
this time you just honestly wanted to see me again
oh no oh I think I screwed up my father
it's it's like he suspects you something
I don't know him oh I just think that
they're planning something with the lap
call me okay oh here comes the
Beast yeah I thought her voice
would calm him down but not that
news what are we doing Jenners
yeah you gotta call your dad
yeah yeah yeah yeah here we go let's do this whoa
all right yes yeah yes oh no whoa oh God all your
research yeah this is like Go
destroy outside of the the lamp
all right that is uh yep that's that's
an impressive amount of Destruction wow
sensory overload don't know if you're
gonna be happy about this after
oh no oh no Atlas Hulk oh
damn yep
solid looking effects in this movie
so far yeah like I was like how did
they put him with the real environment
and make it like it looks good [Music]
a lot of complex feelings right now yeah
oh damn whoa okay you have my word I'll make sure
he's cared for for the next few days at least
you're going to stay away from here and
no Continental services will be extended
every Banner the Continental Hotel is
closed my father's with the military he
seems to think he's involved in some
kind of threat to National Security
the world will not tolerate
his existence will they but you
know
there's nothing I can do for him he's made it
clear he wants nothing to do with me I have
some work to do and I have my scarf to get I'm
the guy who had your father tossed away and why
are you asking me I don't remember don't play
with me four years old when you saw it oh yeah
when Sam Elliott comes at you cough it up what I
mean people repressed strong depressed memories
ever come within a thousand yards of my
daughter again I'll put you away for the
rest of your natural life oh yeah all
right now sign this restraining order
thank you yeah like what is he gonna use that for
make your dog's tracker you're gonna pull some DNA
oh there we go there we go come get her I don't
have nothing standing in your way what oh those
Shadows on the wall look dope hello Bruce so they
think they can just throw you away as they did me
poor guy an alteration genetic I'll remove it
and I'll kill it before it does any real harm I
don't think so I don't know and as for Betty I'm
sending her surprise visit from some four-legged
friends of mine last year I've managed the
culture some of your very own DNA Bruce oh
no oh boy oh my God they're Hulk dogs what
about my DNA sweet s there we go you're crazy
not in front of the government yeah
I wouldn't push him something tells me he wanted
much of it making stupid threats to anyone
dude good luck oh am I
say it
[Music] oh damn oh cool wow nice stunt
s oh
locked off [Music]
wow awesome damn
whoa
whoa oh my goodness not the socks no how he
never tears through his pants he'll never know
he's hiding in there oh
yes no Hulk Hulk
staring
oh geez wow
whoa all right is this a
comic book thing oh my God
[Music]
like Terror dogs yikes Ghostbusters [__]
get out of here poodle that damn poodle
oh
yes
I think so
holy tamale whoa whoa whoa oh bye bye tree
oh my God I would have reversed whoa
man these things are Relentless oh
goodness oh my gosh that looked insane yeah
oh God okay
oh pants finally came off all right all right pee
pants yep it must be the gamma exposure but we've
never seen any effect like this the game I just
Unleashed what was already there at least what
Bruce Banner is there anything from when you
were changed it was like a dream about what
murders God when they hired her they were
like we're gonna need you to cry and like
every every scene yeah she's teared up in every
single scene like I'm like okay girl we just
emotional damn can manifest physically serious
trauma buried memories sir when it comes over me
and I totally lose control I like it yeah you do
what the damn it I'm gonna take you someplace hey
Bruce huh nice
[Music] ah yep some place
safe [Music] thank you oh
those good old fried memories I guess if you want
to dig those memories up it's a good place to be
cool
wow wow
wow the deepest underground base why is he such
a threat to you because I know where he comes
from he says he doesn't know his father but he's
working in the same exact God field his father did
I know the government thinks they have a weapon
on their hands otherwise he'd be dead by now
God all they want in the meanwhile
just let me try to help him nobody
knows him better than I do come on
dad what did David Banner do to him
okay I mean too like if you're gonna use it for a
potential weapon you're going to want a good under
a little bug control do a little bit of research
you know what I'm saying I love my research
so what are we gonna do we're
gonna try this on ourselves of
course we are it's gonna go well
it's gonna go it's gonna be great
oh okay
oh yeah oh oh
what what's going on there what
is that
oh the starfish
up oh is he gonna become the Abomination [Music]
whoa oh he's like uh yeah camouflaging
it oh interesting anything you touch you
become that's gonna be tough because
it's metal oh wow interesting that's
a cool visual yeah that's a very cool
visual I'm gonna have to ask you to
put your hands up pal okay nice and easy well do
you really believe that I am separate from you
interesting it's almost like
he's like gorilla glow where am I
of your home
I don't know if that's what I would
call it yeah that doesn't look like
a like a home to me oh but they can take
walks in the desolate Wasteland yeah and
go to that melted down ice cream
shop this is my old house isn't it
yeah Mama was standing right out there let's go
to remember you're gonna have to go in
that room the room where it happened
there we go is starting to unlock
it are you afraid we'll see
there's nothing it's empty nah bro that wasn't
the point of this exercise you didn't see it but
a ton of bad memories just came tumbling
out of that doorway when you opened it
NSA has decided to turn over study
of the uh the threat to Atheon
[Applause]
I thought she'd put up a little bit more of a
fight these idiots man haven't they ever seen
a werewolf movie gotta have the one girl calms
him down otherwise all hell's gonna break loose
oh hello there you got roughed up bro and
I can carve off a piece of the real you
analyze it patented make a fortune this is
a very bad idea you turn green and all these
guys come in and kill you and I perform
the autopsy maybe my actually go too far
break your neck or maybe he just kills you and
everyone else there yeah you know consciously
oh oh we're going deep all right
let's jump start those brain waves
[Music]
that gives me like claustrophobia Vibes yeah
I did miss Ross welcome back you don't have to
worry I'm not angry with you but you wouldn't
like it if I was angry if you could persuade
your father that if I turn myself in now
peacefully that he would let me see my son
well this is a good idea you should blame yourself
for what you've done to your son and what have I
done to my son well you know buddy oh you've given
Bruce is fear and distance yeah fear of life and
emotional scars I could tell from the moment she
conceived that it wasn't the son I had given her
a monster maybe what but they took away my
chance to cure him your father threw me out
I remember that day so what I knew I was doing
a father's work fulfilling father's Mercy
oh my he's gonna kill Bruce
and kill the mom instead
it was as if ah she and the knife
hey yeah that's one way to put it that is a hell
of a repressed memory yeah yep and transformed
into nothing more Than A Memory he's oh no
that's some sad [__] sir negative on drill
penetration damn it drilling harder give me
pull our pants come on Holmen come on please
now when he be hulking let's get it no I can't
do anything with goo come on [Music] didn't look
like there was enough additional space
to account for the water displacement
[Music]
I feel like he could bypass that oh maybe not she
says it out you know send in our containment team
non-lethals only I repeat non-lethals only I must
have a sample of him a minute ago you're like I'm
gonna kill you in here yeah say anything under
control General I'll let you know if we need you
immediately I want a full court evacuation holy
tamale this might give you
a bit of a sting here Bruce
ah in the actual F why does it
have to be there [Music] big boy
it's terrific [Music]
nice I mean gotta observe this have we learned
anything they're clearly bouncing off this dude
yeah come on now get out while you can notice the
severe lack of bullet wounds blood yeah get it
oh that looks awesome Ultimate Frisbee show him
the way out we'll fight him outside I guess I okay
whoa nice okay nice
no [Music]
no okay wow what
oh
what the whoa wow dude
cool wow that's awesome all about
sensory some of this stuff is it's
like almost tactile in a very different
way yeah like you can feel it with the
sounds and the the way that it's shot
I feel like well it's like no yeah and
they give you like enough air in some of
these moments to like just kind of yeah
hahaha
[Music]
yeah I'd be like burp let's turn
around now yeah [Music] thank you
shake them down that's great yeah Shield geez
smash tell you right now Hulk makes me want to
go to a rage room yeah right rage it out both
to a rage room and also on a road trip through the
country a trampoline there you go trampoline park
hmm
yes just shoot him more the battle must begin
you gotta know not to get that close at very least
what has a close call angle one clear
[Music]
so I'm loving these locations geez I'm like part
of me is like Zach's packed and
exciting but also how beautiful
is he hold oh he is that's awesome
let it go at just the right time
oh nice me at this point I feel like they should
have learned not to hit him physically let's try
to emotionally hurt him yes that might work
let's ridicule him turn it into a parking lot
oh this is National Treasure I mean you
really he's broken through buildings and
through ceilings y'all you think that's really
gonna do it this is what we know how to do
this isn't where I parked my car he's headed
your way probably right for you I'm already here
father and now it's all good news no it's not
dad's got some some of his sleeve and by something
up his sleeve I mean his arm has literally
become the texture and fabric of the sleeve
okay we're a clear Target fire at will it's a cool
detail with the maps on his knees [Music] Wowie
I have so many mere misses
okay oh smart nice take him on
a ride to the top of the world
let's see what the thin air will do
for him okay that's a decent plan
yeah what will it do oh yeah just break
the glass and get in the plane yeah
out of my envelope whoa yeah in their
Legend I can't maintain Hulk had it
says before you maybe not oh that's cool laughs
wow uh oh
another nightmare
huh uh
nice whoa okay puny humans whoa speaks
[Music] you gotta work with
the puny human man in the water
oh boy I feel like she has cast for so
many of these types of roles like she's
the long-suffering companion to the guy who's
going through some extraordinary [__] yep
just Beauty killed the Beast
I mean I feel like they
might have figured that out
give him a chance to calm down
it seems so simple aircraft
oh my God all right here comes
Hulk I was about to ask what is
this doing to the utilities
and the infrastructure Wowie
okay awesome stunt there God High School score
parachute out of there go to him yeah
[Music]
oh [Music] huh full
transformation yeah oh weird
weird oh you found me oh
you aren't that hard to find [Laughter] yes I was
buried in here under all these repressed memories
they were pretty strong but not stronger than our
love love is the true radiation it unlocks the
potential meantime if he does anything but sit
there in that chair I'm gonna turn on the juice
he'll be incinerated immediately okay I mean calm
down she's right she's right here she solved a lot
of your problems shouldn't you just be like thank
you the Nuance is staring you in the face guys I
should have killed you I should have killed you
I wish you had I saw her last night she reached
down kissed my cheek I can almost remember a smell
my mother I don't even know her name sorry I said
let it out maybe once you were my father
but you're not now and you never will be I
didn't come here to see you to see my son the
one inside of you you can think what you like
I don't care just go am I making you angry my
cells can transform too but unlike you they're
unstable I need strength ugh oh okay damn it man
now you must give it back to me stop stop what wow
I'll go you just watch me go hit it oh
whoa
oh boy
holy junk what what what going on
Doctor Manhattan right now okay
hit it again we can't sir there's no power
some kind of counter electromagnetic field
what you've done it now oh cause he can
absorb all the electricity oh sure the power
what whoa okay whoa
I am Holy junk what are they like
fighting through the clouds what is ah
[Music] oh
wow yes yikes that looks scary oh no oh
it's like the rock monster from Galaxy Quest
are there any elements off limits
oh boy okay you can't take water form that's
right keep fighting the more you fight the more
of you I take so you have to learn to control
it so he don't get it kid start meditating Hulk
Struggle No More and give me all of your power
of course take it take it off oh damn yes yes wow
[Music]
whoa oh my gosh she's turning
into a twister [Music]
oh it's too much whoa like oh wow I
mean you asked for it man damn [Music]
oh it's like a nuclear like oh
wow nuclear trauma memory cloud
oh okay okay well we both know that
Bruce couldn't survived that blast
but if by some chance he did survive
you should try to contact you you'll try to
get in touch you tell me wouldn't you no no I
wouldn't you know as well as I do I wouldn't have
to phones are bad my computer's tapped I'm under
surveillance what are you talking about no you're
not if you were alive I'm the last person I would
want him to come to I am so sorry I know you are
see like in the room with her right now it's Gotta
Be there's got to be some kind of yeah secret
someplace the bugs can't tapadre medicine okay
uh cheapers no okay rude what's going on here
yeah buddy nice oh yeah yeah oh here we go
oh man [Music] and of course Forest
looks like a fungus Fade to Green perfect
love it well done that was good times I did
enjoy that you know this movie gets a very
weird rap I feel I feel like there are a lot of
differing opinions about it but uh I had a good
time I had a good time I did think like in the
beginning it was a little slow like I wanted
finally when he was kind of starting to Hulk out I
got like excited when the music started to kick in
you're like all right let's get to it they did
take their time and the last shots would which
I did like like taking time with the character
and his life and what came before I enjoyed yeah
um and but yeah there was there was some moments
where I was like we could cut into these a little
bit faster to give us like quicker juice but I
was all right with the with the pacing overall
as it is Once from Finish to end I was like all
right I get it this is a style I like it I I
liked the Transitions and the editing a lot um
and Jennifer Connelly single tear man Bravo yes
she really does hold it down for this kind of
role in particular but I was happy to have her
here like I I enjoyed Eric Bana and uh Jennifer
Connelly quite a bit I mean you know they they
have a little bit of there could be a little bit
more warmth to their chemistry but I feel like it
makes sense as to who especially Bruce is and all
this sort of like repressed stuff and everything
but yeah I would agree like it definitely moves
and I've heard people describe I think Greg has
described this before as like it's much more of
like a comic book Drama than it is like a super
zero action flick yeah and I could definitely see
this not exactly being what people want ideally
want it out of a a big Hulk movie like this but
I I find it really fun to peer back into you know
the earlier phases of this kind of Cinema because
this is I mean you know this is kind of not this
form of movie but just the philosophy is I feel
like what we're sort of trying to return to which
is like the Zhang Lee clearly he had a vision for
this or at least it seems like he was really able
to you know direct this movie and put his earmarks
on it and so like I appreciated that it allowed
the scenes to breathe and I appreciated yeah the
comic book editing and stuff like that like all
the actors showed up like even though the Third I
guess you'd call that like a third actor third act
fourth act like when he when he finally uh meets
when uh David Banner father Banner comes back to
see him and then absorbs all the energy and then
you get this like that bit felt a little tacked
on just because it's like oh yeah I guess we
should have him go up against like a super powered
villain of some kind with like true ill intent not
just the military who is sort of uh you know uh
bullishly you know sort of firing at him all over
the place like even though they are antagonistic
to Hulk because we understand Hulk you're like
I get it they're trying to you know protect a
their interest but also B people from getting
wantonly Massacre taking care of them right
um so yeah but Dad went at him emotionally
that's true you see what I was saying they were
physically dad was like I'm gonna get in here yeah
and I'm like as much as this movie could certainly
be tighter or shorter or more again of like a an
action movie in its focus I I you know by the end
you get there and you're like yeah like everything
got its opportunity to uh just grow you know the
the story of you know Bruce's trauma and what
he had to deal with as a child that stuff being
repressed uh coming back into uh contact with
his father and sort of having his life turned
upside down by that and then ultimately at the
end his dad coming back to finish the research
all that stuff just felt like it it unfolded
pretty naturally uh and you know everything with
Betty Ross and uh and her father you know yeah
um I don't know yeah it's like everything felt
like it was given the amount of breathing room it
needed nothing felt like it was like overly choppy
and yeah sometimes you are like maybe we could
speed this up a little bit but I did like that it
was graceful and it didn't feel again yeah like it
was cut up in a blender or something or like there
were a bunch of interests they had to get to or
something like it felt like its own own movie and
I like that yeah and I felt like that like even
with the time they had I'm like you could have
maybe without all the montages of like environment
and helicopters and shooting him a bunch in it not
working I'm like oh would have been cool to see
a little bit more of him and Betty relationship
Foundation just at the top so that sure we felt a
little bit more like when he looks at her at the
end all they needed was like her in the helicopter
looking at him and they can tell that like oh that
works oh all right oh all right just like but
I guess put your weapons down okay go see him
um I I it could maybe hit a little bit
harder for us of feeling that connection
yeah possibly if if we had a little bit
more of their relationship at the top but
um still overall I was like yeah the I mean Hulk
dogging it he had to take care of them and then
save her and I was like that was cool like uh that
felt like a thing out of a comment yes book movie
that felt like a bit of a different kind of like
most things that happened even the finale fight
with his dad felt like pretty well attuned to what
this is but the the Hulk dogs did feel kind of
if that was very like Fantastical comic bookie in
a different way like this felt like largely like
a drama that was using some comic book visuals and
language to kind of you know embellish itself and
to kind of split the difference but that really
felt like a comic book thing yeah and Nick Nolte
at the end when he got all Nick Nolte yeah when
he gives that speech I was like oh he's off his
rocker now let's do it Nick and he went all the
way he went all the way like I gotta I gotta you
know I I joke about Nick Nolte sometimes but
I mean he is a good actor and he shows up like
when he shows up he shows up that's the thing is
I feel like you could have easily not shown up to
this movie in so many of the different roles and
I thought everybody everybody did and I would be
curious to know what people think of Eric Bana
as Bruce Banner because obviously I'm not the
expert on like what is the most Comics accurate
or whatever um but I liked his presence yeah like
it would have been nicer to see a little bit
of their love and their romance just to drive
that home into feel yeah that kind of warmth
that they're fighting to get back to and maybe
drive home the idea that like oh like you know it
logically makes sense that she would be the thing
to calm him down but like if you had that little
extra oomph so that you could really feel that I
think that would have been kind of neat it also
would have made um is it the other guy like more
of a villain her ex-boyfriend like if if they're
Josh the Josh Lucas guy yeah yeah yeah the Josh
Lucas guy like if if her and Eric Bana were like
you know a solid and then what does not swings in
and then it would have made him a little bit
more of a villain yeah totally a little bit
God and that too like that I mean he is of the
character like I really like that they gave Ross
as much as he is an antagonist through a lot of
this and especially in his younger form he is
very sort of standoffish I did like the way they
humanized him whereas I do feel like Talbot the
Josh Lucas character is like the most of all the
human villains he is the most sort of like he's
like Justin Hammer but but like shittier yeah he's
yeah he's uh he's just a complete opportunist with
no s common sense for like the situation in front
of him he's just trying to get to that bottom line
um but you know I feel like it's funny because
Josh Lucas I feel like gets put into that role
a lot too where he's like you know some kind of
either rival in a similar lane or just somebody
who's there to a kind of swoop in and and you know
get in on on you know a potential relationship
with the girl the protagonist is in love with but
also he's just kind of like a business douche like
what's that movie with Julia Roberts he's exactly
that where she's the money and the well and it's
bad water and he's there oh yeah come on guys
yeah Aaron Brockovich that movie he's in that
and he plays what he's saying and it was carabono
from stranger things who was his mom it was yes
okay yeah yeah this is this is interesting this
is fun I liked I liked a lot of the settings and
stuff like that and I loved that they it's funny
we see a lot of desert battles now the flash
recently just had one and and I feel like often
times nowadays people are like ah man these drab
fight scenes just out in some kind of desolate you
know desert tan backdrop and I really loved it's
like that felt like the climactic action scene
when you know he's escaping the base and all
the militaries coming after him and stuff like
that and he's like traversing the country yeah
but I thought that stuff was beautiful like they
really used locations nicely and I thought they
also shot their effects really well because for
2003 I think this looks really good in a lot of
respects like yeah some of the full sunlight shots
you're like of course it's CG but like so much of
this stuff they shot in partial Shadow and they
still managed to put in little flourishes like
the sprinkler coming down in that one scene that
like helped to sell it Beyond just like oh smart
you're not having to use as much detail um but
yeah like showing him on screens and things like
that or from afar and just the way they handled
the physics of the Hulk uh yeah just like really
nicely I thought drawn and so again like meeting
this halfway as a superhero drama I was like
pretty pretty interesting pretty decent like
there's a lot of uh interesting and quality work
that went into this and I think yeah especially
with how far the effects the CG has come on a
character like alcohol 2003 though I was like
wow he's like moving around that environment
things aren't moving and that thing looks real
and I know he's not but it like the way that
they melded the environment together for like old
school CG I was like yeah good job yes yeah they
did a really nice job with that and uh yeah I
mean overall overall I liked it it was it was
felt like a little long for me I was like oh
but overall I like I like the movie yeah and I
and I also appreciated that there was like again
I'm not the biggest Hulk expert necessarily but
I did enjoy uh having this additional element
with the prologue and everything and his father
experimenting on himself you know it's not just
the gamma radiation that unlocks the Hulk it's
all this other genetic material that has been
experimented with and then passed along to Bruce
thought that stuff was was nicely done and even
the thing with the repressed memories and like the
inherited trauma and stuff like that it just
like it felt like uh like Angeli and Company
really thought about this and uh and and even if
again it's not like the exact blueprint of like
your ideal superhero joint I think they still like
managed to help pave the road in a really nice way
and there are aspects of this I would love to see
you know come back in some way also just a quick
final thought uh justice for Daniel Day Kim is in
this movie yeah and he's in like two scenes and
he's just like kind of he's just like an assistant
too he's like here's the file sir yeah he's just
an assistant to Thunderbolt Ross when he's got
comic book movie cred as well from uh uh Hellboy
and some other things so I don't know this is a
fun little little deep but uh any any other uh
points or Deets you want to go over before
we hit the road just don't repress those bad
memories I mean like keep them down but then
like maybe let him out so then they're they're
out you know so you're not like hurting like
he was for a long time you know be honest with
yourself yeah therapy is a great the therapy you
know yes it is that's a that's a bar better help
should contact you and and license that quote
I was in a better help commercial I thought
that's where John was going that there you go
I was in a parachute you guys wouldn't even be
able to recognize me I think I dropped it on my
YouTube channel when I was in it two years ago
you can do the research if those brand dollars
Tara Eric hey baby well guys I hope you're not
angry that we checked this movie out and if you
are leave a comment below expressing your anger
that's a better way to do it than going out and
destroying things leave a like on the video let
us know what else you'd like us to check out and
uh hey before we hit the road let's do a page
Daniel gallacher you know where this is
going buddy I know you you're easy he lives
in Scotland he's a pharmacist among other
things or he works you know at a pharmacy
and so I feel like if anybody at our patreon is
in the prime position to do some off the Record
experimentation maybe enhance his physiology
and maybe unlock some repressed memories in
the process it's Daniel gallacher all right
and I cannot wait for the potential of what
you might turn into who you might Hulk
out as you know Mercy's gotta makes up
the drugs though because he's got he's got to
do the pharmacy the drugs and then and all his
different genes yeah and then he can Hulk out oh
yeah but no no testing on animals yeah all good
experiments are tested on yourself that's what
I've learned from every movie that's true and
that's what what better way to go than doing
what you love Yeah and uh we love you we love
that you're pledged to the patreon so no matter
what you turn into just make sure you're in the
same way that uh that uh Bruce Banner left his
wallet at the lab that first time he hoped out
leave yours at the patreon before you go out into
the world and do whatever hulking you're gonna
do so uh hey buddy we love you stay pledged and
we'll catch you next month let's smash bye [Music]